good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the uh review meeting uh
relating to M Farm I'll read out the
emergency evacuation notice to start
with and then we'll do the
introductions please note that this
meeting will be recorded should be we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the room by the door
the far St staircase please hold both
hand rails in case the stairs are wet or
slippery if anyone is unable to use the
stairs would they please allow others to
exit the room before they go for far
escape doors where they can be given
assistance our assembly point will be in
the public car park inside of the Civic
Suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect belongings please
do not return to the building until
given permission to do so by Council
staff good evening my name is Dave
spurring one of the
counselors
hi Chris please take a seat we just
missed the evacuations detailed but I
know you've heard them before so yep
fine
um we have it with us this evening um I
think you've all got the scrutiny the
early list of attendees ion
dun um team leader for planning
enforcement Martin how principal
environmental officer Susanne Armstrong
s County Council enforcement officer and
and also as it says here in the second
group Ian Ward and Angela law uh just to
introduce our colleagues here coun Robie
Dre Jack lman
Jo Chris black John Griffin John Mason I
think know Michelle and and Paul
C how we've structured this we've had a
few meetings and we have come up which
we call them 20 core questions which I
believe you already had copies of um
what we will do is one of the councilors
will ask the
question which hopefully you'll answer
there will be supplementary questions
subject to your responses and then we'll
carry on when we exhausted question one
we've answer to two if we find that
answer two actually covers most of
question 8 as well we will say that
we've eliminated that and then just move
on if you got any questions please let
us know we start off um we start off
with Robie do you want to go with first
core question Rob and we'll thank you
David um what role does the department
uh that you represent have in relation
to
Mitchell so do you want to start with
RDC enforcement yeah okay so um the
enforcement team within the uh planning
department is responsible for
investigating planning
breaches and um
negotiating any uh compliance with the
transgressor to remedy that breach and
if that doesn't uh result in Des desired
outcome uh we have the option uh to
consider whether it's expedient to take
formal action by way of serving an
enforcement
notice obviously if there's
non-compliance with the requirements of
that notice then we have the option to
go for
prosecution okay what about your then
Suzanne I do exactly the same as evil
but I work for ESS County Council as
waste and minerals enforcement officer
so I deal with anything relating to
waste okay can I ask then if both of you
were involved at the very start of this
matter I think you went beyond as off
1999 yes no no I've I did not have any
real involvement in this case at all uh
it's been other officers prior to my
appointment okay and I started at Essex
County Council in 2012 so I became
involved in 2012 okay could I ask
question certainly yes um so with
regards environmental health matters um
some of the things we can do with are
staty nuisances and so that might be one
area where we come in that would be
where something that happens on the site
affects another party uh an instance
here might be whether smoke that might
arise from the site might affect someone
else um we can also deal as the site is
commercial in nature um there's uh
specific legislation uh regarding dark
smoke and emissions of dark smoke so
that would be an area we could be
involved in um uh and with an eye to
current future issues land contamination
is an area where we would have a
regulatory role as well uh in terms of
my time I've been employed uh in the
Environmental t uh since
2001 um but uh from the outset I should
say that we we've had very little
involvement with this site over time uh
and uh indeed my first visit to the site
was was this year this cend year
okay the environment agency of course
they got a role as well they so the
environment agency yes they're they're a
um obviously they're a national
regulatory body they're very closely
assoc associated with the waste issues
that are on the Su um now there's a fair
degree of overlap I think with with
particular County Planning enforcement
side um but they would regulate the
movement of waste the storage of waste
uh and and the treatment of waste as
well is there any John ask a
supplemental question on that I mean
obviously we've got enforcement and two
authorities and we've got Environmental
Protection Environmental Health in one
Authority and I just want to get a feel
for in terms of the balance and
weight is that was the is the situation
was the situation more weighted towards
one or the other in terms of
responsibility and lead in other words
is it
predominantly a an Enforcement issue or
predominantly an environment issue what
is the what is the balance and waiting
in terms of what needed to be
done um I can pick up on that first off
um I mean initially back in 1999 when
the case was first opened we were
looking at whether or not there had been
a material change of use of the land um
when you look back at site photographs
at that time there was not necessarily
any importation of waste on the scale
that we've witnessed since it was more
that the site was being used to store a
number of
vehicles um and there was some car
repairs going on the site there was also
um I mean obviously the site's quite
large there was also horses grazing on
that land so you know it wasn't in the
condition that you know it it got to in
2010 when it was probably at its worse
so initially it was about the material
change of use of the land it was only
then when um you know that importation
of waste started to get to the scale
where there was a concern that I think
that actually County actually sort of
became
involved in terms of our timeline which
we presumably shared with you um what
point did it become more an
environmental matter then rather than
enforcement um well the environment
agency I think picked it up um in about
um I mean we served notices back in 2002
um but the environment agency picked it
up I think in about
200 uh excuse me I'm just referring to
my notes about 2006 I think was when
they
first yeah I mean we we started to I
think there was a fire that occurred
back in June
2005 and then at that point I think the
environment agency began to began to
sort of look at it in more detail is
that correct I don't have a record
earlier than that no May 2005 is is my
Department's first awareness of the sign
yeah so there were enforcement notices
in place on the land prior to the
environment agency taking place that R
should itself
serve okay go
sorry I listen to that I'll go back to
2002 when you say I feel against but
that's when you start to get the notes
sered it takes a year to get statements
according to this and then your first
summons is in 2003 and then we go
through quite a long time but what I'm
so there is a there there's a question
over the period of time it's talk but
also the second question is we go
through when you look at the 2002
storage of waste materials um got
vehicles of course erection of building
planning so really when you look at it
across the board mix of issues here
waste and so on did anyone of you or did
you all what was the collaboration and
who took the lead who took the lead
through this who was the lead Authority
and how did you
collaborate um well if I pick up on that
point first and then if anybody wants to
um add on that's fine um at this time
the the storage of the tires wasn't I
mean we did had some correspondents I
think from the environment agency the
storage of the tires wasn't considered
to be waste so um the storage of waste
materials I think that was probably part
and parcel of the cars as well because
some of the cars when we look back at
the photographs they weren't actually
roadworthy so they weren't there to be
um you know repaired and then moved on
they were in various states of um you
know um poor poor State you know like
sort of chass parts of the car missing
Etc so that could have been the bulk of
the waste that was actually um being
referred to however um I think there
were pockets and we look at some of the
photographs there were pockets of waste
material but um I don't
know um what whether or not the um essis
County Council were involved at that
stage or not and that was when Tony was
so we have no record of what that waste
material was well we have have
photographs but I don't think when we
look back at the photographs around 2001
2002 too when we took the decision to
serve the notices it wasn't of the
significant scale that we have looked at
since then it was predominant as I said
it predominantly Green Field with like
just this small area that he had cars
stored and some tires stored um just on
that question you got one two we got
quite a few issues there yes and it was
enough for you to take prosecution but
it wasn't enough to involve other people
um well as I say I can't
I'm no no no that's fine no I do
understand
um it with esss hand council's waste
planning Authority we do there there is
no real definition of waste a district
can deal with some like if there's cars
waste is something that you intend to
discard or required to discard so it
means you're disposing of it even though
it may be referred to waste it may not
be a definition of waste which falls
with under the remit of ESS County
Council as Waste Authority we would have
to prove there it's a change of use of
use of the land for disposal purposes
now even though it may refer to waste
that could still just become a district
matter so it wouldn't necessarily be
something that the Waste Authority can
be involved in it would still fall
within the district and I believe at
this time it was a matter that been
dealt with by the district and which a
notice was served at that time so you
answered the question it was a district
that was a lead at that time that time
that's what I'm trying to establish John
do you want
to oh sorry just going to add a a point
yes at the time that that material might
arrive on a site it might not be waste
at that time but it might become waste
without anything else happening to it it
might simply be because of a passage of
time time yeah so in terms of
environment agency involvement in terms
of any regulation that may have gone on
in terms of that material getting to the
site may not have been necessary may not
have been waste then so in terms of how
agencies relate things can change
without seemingly anything visually
changing on site okay do you want to
finish this section off John yes thank
you you one of you said um that tires
weren't necessarily
waste clearly at some point in the legis
in
legislation tires do become waste
because there is a necessity to carry
out particular procedures for their
disposal so my question is at what point
and by What legislation did tires then
become regulated in terms of the
conditions and circumstances and
procedures for their disposal because
clearly at that point they represented a
a risk that had been covered by
legislation I mean that is something
that the environment agency would have
picked up it was the environment agency
that um when I spoke to Tim sheeper from
the environment agency he said that when
those tires were first brought to the
site they were being stored there
because they were be going to be used
for another purpose um and um they there
was a company that was actually going to
be using those and some of those tires
had actually started to leave the site
when the environment agent see we're
actually dealing with it but I don't
know about legislation unless Martin you
know about the EA's legislation well I
think we're going to cover that the next
question I know we are we still won't
get an answer to it because I've asked
it and it's it's a principle question
because you know when something becomes
controlled in terms of its disposal then
and obviously its level of risk
obviously increases and therefore the
level of activity to deal with it or see
it dealt with then becomes a higher
priority and I really want to get get an
answer to that question at some point
before we not tonight necessarily but
before we finish this report I mean we
can go back to the environment agency
and ask for Clarity on it I mean we did
get a response from the environment
agency that was passed to
view wasn't it I think it resp yeah but
unfortunately they're not here
tonight um do you feel that um
the the lack of definition of of waste
for instance caused a delay in the
overall
investigations I don't feel it caused a
delay in the investigation because I
think um you know Rochford were quite
clear I mean because they served the
enforcement notice in 2002 they were
quite clear as to what they considered
to be the breaches of planning to
control that they were dealing with what
we were dealing with it was obviously um
as time went on then obviously the
condition the site changed there was
more importation naturally evolved most
definitely okay okay I think we've just
about established the responsibilities
as in question one um I've been too Keen
to get involved in the the questioning
section I'm afraid we've got to do a
little bit of routine housework here um
I've got to record the go back to the
agenda very briefly uh ladies and
gentlemen apologies for absence we have
received from councilor Les puer Michael
ho and our
chairman Jo Gibson um we have one non
member
attending apologies
from car
Carol ping yes put that include that one
please um One n member attending I
believe is I
Ward um we just have to confirm the
minutes of the meeting of 6th of
October were in order AG yes thank you
and if we have any Declarations of
Interest which I don't believe we will
have but I'm asking a question my only
declaration is my oh yeah
same yeah that's okay well let's move on
as it's your W let we let you go with
question call question number two okay
this is for everybody really that's the
officers um what what powers do they do
you have to visit the site and to ensure
that identify request for remedial work
is compli
with okay well this question I can
answer for both myself and Suzanne
because we both work under the Town and
Country planning act um section 196a of
that act uh permits us to enter sites to
actually carry out investigations to um
assess whether or not there's been a
breach planning control and to monitor
that um I think the actual um regulation
state that we can do that without
obstruction so um if somebody does
obstruct us having access onto the site
then um you know obviously that we can
actually sort of take further steps um
but yeah and also that applies to the um
Insurance to um for remedial Works to be
done as well non-compliance of
enforcement notices we've got the option
to actually sort of take action
prosecute in the
courts terms of environmental health um
using the x that I referred to earlier
so the Environmental Protection act 19
1990 we've got powers of entry on to the
site there to investigate
nuisances uh we have the Clean Air Act
in 1993 which is in relation to any dark
smoke
fences uh and uh in terms of land
contamination uh is both environment
Environmental Protection act 1990 and
the environment act
1995 so they would be the the sweet we
use you know as as
appropriate yeah then the reason I ask
that is is because most most sort of
definitions if you like have a have a a
purpose I lawful excuse a reasonable
excuse to give you that power or the
reason of Need for energy can you
enlighten me a little bit on what what
excuse would you need to have the reason
you can't just walk in there must be a
grounds for your forite visit that's
what I'm looking for so under that what
is your reasonable excuse or your
understanding or your cuse to take you
in because obviously it's got to be
legal and then how do you recall that
how is it recorded you you you talk
about photograph for example if you saw
things you you you have a record of your
what Your poers of
Entry not just entry but what is the
power of Entry SP a little bit no that's
fine that's fine because the the actual
Town and Country planning act talks
about obviously the enforcement of
planning
legislation um and um any any the
planning act in general I mean a a a
planning officer um dealing with a an
application for planning permission can
actually has the right to actually go
onto a site to carry out their duties um
I mean it's clearly printed on the back
of my passcard and on occasions when
I've had to go onto a site because for
example I've you know wanted to look at
a breach of uh planning control and
there's doesn't appear to be anybody
about I've gone on to the site and there
some appears and they've questioned my
authority to be on the site I'm actually
able to quote what's on the back of my
past card and it actually quotes that
part of the ACT um which basically says
that this offic is authorized to go onto
the site to investigate breaches of
planning control or suspected breaches
planning control I thank you for that I
respect that I do respect all of that
but what I'm looking for is what caus
did you get a letter of a complaint what
calls you to make the visit and if so it
must be recorded somewhere and what did
that complaint say what was the nature
of the complaint I think we' um you
wouldn't just go down and say have a
look at that sign no no you're right nor
I mean normally breaches are either
report reported To Us by members of the
public or it's something that an officer
um is alerted to when they're out and
about on site um I believe the
complainant originally was
um was a member of the public but I'd
have to check that for you I mean if you
could because it's more from nobody this
place we got to yeah unfortunately it's
it has got a very good view it might you
might not be able to see it too clearly
when you're actually right adjacent site
but you can see from the a130 or be was
it there in 99 the
a130 but the the railway line runs to
the nor side I'm just interested to know
how they all come but we can come back
to you on that who yeah I mean obviously
um we wouldn't be giving details cuz
it's confidential but we're happy to
sort of say you have to edit someone's
name I don't want that but you want to
know whether or not it's a member of
public or whether or not it was a
council officer there
or John do you want to while we're on
these on the visits and and and why they
were the visits do you want to tie this
with with core question 10 which is the
numerous science visits and what were
their purposes yes I I'd love to um the
timeline was very helpful um I'm
grateful
for if we can go on to question 10 and
joh will come in on the
T the time that obviously you gave to it
um I'm I'm a little perplexed about the
entry on page five of the timeline
which May
20133 May 2013 site visit no details at
all November 2013 site visit no details
at all um that's within you know living
memory um so it doesn't have the excuse
I feel that you know you guys weren't um
in post or something and at least there
should be records as to who went on the
site visit what the purpose of the site
Vis it was and more particularly on
those occasions what was observed and
were any actions um
considered okay sorry sorry I
can the the reason being is we both had
different enforcement
notices um on the site which will
probably come up later in time Essex
County council's enforcement notice
compliance date was due 22nd of May
2013 so therefore a visit was carried
out in May 2013 to check compliance with
ESS County council's enforcement notice
the visit would be recorded under essit
County council's information due to the
site it would had to be all officers the
environment agency ESS County Council
and rodford visit the site together to
take
photographs of what was seen on that day
but you've got no record to share with
us I have I have record yes and the same
for November
13th
I mean this we could possibly yeah every
site visit would have a
record photographs can you can you give
us
a uh a report on those side visits after
this meeting yes
it if I just pick up here also um
Council Mas is that this is possibly an
oversight on my part because I was asked
to um put together the remaining
timeline um and it was just a case of um
plotting the activity on the site um
hence I just put site visit I mean I
could have quite easily have given some
more detail so that was an error and
oversight on my part but we can I can go
back on the file and look to see what um
the officer actually observed on site he
would have no doubt taken
photographs so we can um we can fill in
the gaps there for for you if it would
be helpful I'm it' be very grateful
thank you for being you know so open
with that response um I really would
like to see the could we see the
originals of the reports please rather
than ay because those are critical
periods and I'm sure other members would
like to see DET I mean they will just be
like handwritten notes that the officer
would have taken at the
time understand yeah do you do you want
to come in Jack or if I
mayman sorry joh you that's yeah go
on they're collaborating see the thing
is that we come back to my first
question you said sorry if I point you I
don't mean but you said for example oh
I've got this and blah blah blah and the
lady up the India was a little bit sort
of like a little bit puzzled what you
were going to say you know there and I I
come back to this point what was the
joint action you know you seem to have
all been doing your thing and I'm not
saying you wasn't but you don't don't
seem to have collaborated and made a
joint attack on this isue can can I say
that I think Jack has moved on to core
question number
four I'm
sorry I apologize so that's all
right obviously enough of the other
questions so we move on I mean I think
you know it has naturally moved into
core question number four which is do
you have an agreed strategy that you
follow and I think we pretty much
started to get to this this area now so
perhaps you could Enlighten us if you do
have a an agreed core strategy or how
you addressed the situation you are now
finding yourselves
in uh yes I mean we do have a a guide to
enforcement which details how we um deal
with um sets out how we deal with
Enforcement cases I mean that's a
council document with regards to this
specific site um as been you know as
been explained we've all got our own
areas that we deal with and initially it
was you know planning enforcement at a
district level and then obviously we did
then start to collaborate with Essex
County when we realized that there was
you know more of an issue with the
importation of waste um and um from 2005
I think um environmental health were
also in correspondence with the
environment agency so I think from sort
of the mid 2000
then there was more of a collaborative
strategy um but at the same time you
know we've got our own Fields um that
we're actually dealing with on the
case yeah that comes across right yeah
that comes across there no criticism of
you personally but what I'm looking at
is is here we have a situation you've
only got to look at this running log of
what happened is we've got a serious
there's no question there's a serious
development here as it progresses it's
snowb it gets larger and larger and what
seems to be immediately coming across is
there was no join process you got you've
all doing a process I'm not saying
you're not you don't because if I into
me personally I could see this if we
were all collaborating together as one
one case you would have far more impact
on whatever it is you were trying to
resolve because the evidence you've all
got together would be greater than you
working apart and that's the impression
I'm getting that you're working
individually yeah I mean perhaps I'm
wrong yeah I think I think the reason I
could answer the bit relating to may we
I don't want to go into too much
confusing watchword started many year
many years before and there was some
notices served now esset Count Council
came in in 2009
2010 so we also served a notice
unfortunately notices are appealed and
the inspector on our particular notice
gave an extra year so therefore our
dates then do not tie up with Rochford
so we then have two different cases
where one inspector might give six
months to comply an extra 6 months or
our one gave a year so therefore in our
case there was an extra year to comply
the notice whereas in Rochford there was
less time so then we was all out of
different time scale that's my point you
know you you've got one person doing
left right left right the other person's
going right left right left you're all
doing the same walk but you're going
down different dire unfortunately we all
start together if there appeals we can
have different inspectors a district to
a county you can have a inspector
looking at the county Wayside and think
they need an extra time a year but that
will not necessarily be the same
inspector for the district I sorry I
understand we say I do fully understand
you be very clear what things be coming
across this that you're not talking to
each other because when that decision
was considered what action did you take
to talk to the other party were they or
then to you yeah we were we were we were
talking but obviously the reason I came
in on the May is because that is
particular that day is to my notice so
straight away I remembered at my notice
was due for compliance whereas I know
that Rochford was January so I knew
straight away that
the reason for not a lot of details put
in on their site visit is because it's
more in relation to esss County
council's enforcement I mean going back
as far as um sort of June
2006 um and it's not on your timeline
this is additional evidence that I've
found from the files um we had an email
from our own environmental health um
Department about some dark smoke that
have been a complaint about some dark
smoke coming from the site and um they
advised us that um you know it would be
dealt with in partnership with the
environment agency and that the
environment agency were now going to
investigate the site for the um you know
for for their under their
regulations um and and from that point
the EA were then involved and there was
this when the EA did a site visit they
would email um Rocha District Council
the result of their site visit with
photographs and when we did uh site
visit ourselves if we found anything
that we thought that was pertinent to
the environment agency then that
information was shared I mean and in
October 2006 the environment agency and
there's actually a typo in the timeline
uh the final paragraph on page three
actually says that the Environmental
Health Department um will be looking for
to compile evidence for their own
prosecution that's actually the
environment agency so going back as far
as October 2006 the EA were then looking
to um do a prosecution of the site as
well so from 2006 there was this sharing
of information it is unfortunately as
suzan said you know when we're looking
at uh appeals of enforcement notices and
sort of formal action and prosecution
the time scales just stretch you know
into 6 months into years so um but all
through that time obviously we were
conducting site visits as it as it says
or attempting
to can I just come back with with one
there did was this and this is sort of
touching on question number five while
our involment was quite local was yours
Suzanne I mean was this just one of many
you had across the the the county I
don't know how you split your
responsib so I cover the whole of essic
so this could well have slipped down the
the priority list or is that not the
case this you have no that that wouldn't
have been the case they if though we
cover the whole of
essic when when we called in we have an
enforcement protocol as well which set
out on ESS County Council website of how
we carry out everything to do with
breach of planning
control and probably it's later on that
we became in D in this case okay thank
you for
that can I follow up on that yeah yeah
um I thing I want I've heard is there's
been a lot of exchanging of emails and
information but I didn't hear once that
you actually got together in the same
room and actually talked about a a
combined strategy which I think this is
what council Lawman's getting there a
joint strategy to deal with the issues
that were coming up in other words yes
things were getting out of kilter in
terms of synchronized time but you know
um with gifted lawyers and gifted staff
you you have to find ways around that so
did you get together around a table and
talk about it and if you didn't why
didn't
you well I I can't answer why it wasn't
done obviously because I wasn't involved
at the time um however um yes you're
right there was the exchange of email
and exchange of photographs and we did
do some joint visits together um because
of the difficulties getting on the site
we needed police escort um so those were
done obviously because it was a golden
opportunity to get on the site and have
a good look around with the police we
did that all together so the environment
agency and Rockford would have done a
joint visit um but yeah I mean I'm not
aware that there were actual any sort of
strategy meetings C cly once the EA
decided that uh they were going to be
the lead on the
prosecution um then there was a lot more
exchange but and there may have been
conference calls but I you know I'll be
guessing to definitely give you an
answer that that indeed did
happen I suppose I've got to ask one one
further question I I've got to ask was
there a a coordinated and Joint strategy
between inv environmental health
environment agency ess's County Council
and rot District Council on this
case I can't give you an answer on that
I don't know whether I could say simply
by including the council's environment
Health team in in that list I can say no
because the the the the the involvement
that the my team had uh was very limited
very occasional reports of of smoke uh
and and all at a time where the
environment agency were very proactive
on site
um so no I we weren't involved in a
strategy
but just just to reinforce the point
made out it's an inherent part of the
way we work is intelligent sharing so
that certainly isn't unique to this side
we would habitually share information as
pertinent to one another's cases formly
or otherwise and I think also if I could
just add on to that um councilor Mason
is that that's something that we
certainly do more now um we do
um you know there was the sharing of
information but we certainly do work
closer together now I know it's
something that obviously has come down
from central government that you know
statutary bodies should be working in in
uh conjunction with one another um and
as I say when I go on site now I want to
go on site I always call Suzanne and say
you know let's do the site visit
together so um it's certainly an
approach that we we do now and it's
probably less lesons that you know may
have been learned because of this case
and other cases as well that we've both
had involvement thank you thank you I I
think from from what you've all said we
pretty much covered the the government
legislation that that covers this work
Mike perhaps you'd like to go on to the
other question six which is the other
agencies are involved because from what
you've said over the last few minutes it
becomes fairly obvious that the other
agencies not working together of course
problems in the breakdown of issues that
you were trying to work together
on so of you and yeah so so the question
is what other agencies and or
authorities have been involved in this
case you've already mentioned the police
force be interested just to hear a bit
more about that in terms of what their
view was and if they were able to offer
anything how they were involved yes um
following the the fire that occurred in
March um there were a number of
organizations or or regulatory bodies
came together we had the police we had
the S6 forign rescue Service uh Network
rail so although not um a regulatory
body obviously with the embankment and
the railway line to the side they were
effective party ourselves both planning
environmental health um and the
environment agency in particular and
there were a number of telephone
conference calls after that
about who had been able to contact whom
gather what information home uh at that
time uh I think it's simply limited to
that I have to say there's very limited
contact from any neighboring sit um or
be it the um uh north of the RightWay
line um the the neighbor that is uh the
the electricity um uh company um have
been in contact in a distant past uh
regarding the site um but not in recent
times I don't think they content you no
so uh it's it's quite
limited number of agencies yeah is
anybody else ra on this because I've got
one nobody
else go back to the um the other
question um in relation to um John's
Point regards to the
um uh involvement of the other um
agencies um do you think that um
uh can I come back with a question I'll
come back with a question later yeah I I
mean I the thing I was going to ask and
and and and both the ladies have have
mentioned this we ended up with
different
inspectors taking on different cases
which seemed to me to confuse the the
issue more where you've got one
inspector taking one View and give him
various year whatever the other guy is
making 6 months you you've almost got to
2 3 4 five maybe six different cases
depending on which inspector happens to
be picking it up and I'm from my very
limited assessment of the situation
seems to put that this doesn't help the
the resolving of the issue one iota it
it just actually gives the Mr fits who
was you know seems quite Adept at app
playing the system plenty of scope to to
operate within the the legal par
because of the very there doesn't seem
to be any further thinking should we say
to outside agencies and with the best
will in the world you could all be
working together but the the levels
above you were completely independent is
that a fair assessment of what was going
on at times I think it would be wrong
for us to speculate as to how the
planning inspectorate allocates its
inspectors to certain cases um but a lot
of the time it does depend on inspector
availability uh you know when these
dates are set so
um unfortunately um it does happen
sometimes you know um quite often when
we've gone to court it's quite handy if
you've got the same judge because you
know we've had judges that have got
planning experience and that's been very
helpful to our case but it is also the
case that you don't you don't get a
judge that's got planning experience so
I imagine it's the same things
well not that they haven't
got yeah yeah you want to go back in
regards to I'm pleased to say I'm pleas
to hear that you knew you now have
strategic meetings between all the the
agencies and that's a lesson that you've
learned but do you think that if you'd
had a strategic meeting between all the
agencies in this particular case that it
would have been resolved quicker or it
would have been easier uh for all the
agencies to to do things in a better way
well it would certainly um have helped
with um developing some sort of strategy
whether or not it would have actually
had any effect um again is is is
speculation because a lot of the time as
I say it is the fact that you know we
had difficulty getting on site that
wasn't just us that was the other
agencies as well um you know we have to
make sure that we've got up to-date
evidence before we go for prosecution so
you do need to get on to the site to get
that evidence uh then you've got you
know setting of court dates Etc so all
those delays are things that you know
unfortunately are out of our hands to
some degree um so yeah I I think that
you know to have a strategy where all
the agencies do actually sort of sit
together and and decide on on a plan is
certainly the best way forward but
whether or not it would have had um you
know an effect on the speediness of
actually where we got to where we are
today on well we can only
speculate before I come to you jack I
think we we've effectively drifted into
question number seven which is about
speeding up and slowing down so Jacob
you do you want to car on if I just
before that because it might be in the
question I don't know um I listened and
and it's again you've all gave a good
you know good account basically your
history but clearly you've all had the
same issues but for different par you
know different positions
it's a legal question really it's um and
it's really first of all each each
department or each agency what do you
CLA as a serious issue so in other words
from a 1 to 10 if you like where does
this start to agress to that top of the
ladder and if so you're all having
prosecutions and you're all saying
you're saying like this case went off to
this date this went off to that date was
there any legal Cooper cooperation in
terms of statements because one person
could be saying one thing to you and
then saying something different to
Michael something different and so did
you share your evidence was there a
common legal framework for this for
prosecution and why if not why not
because although you've got different
enactments and different laws and so on
I'm sure a joint prosecution under the
right circumstances might be appropriate
and I'm just questioning that really if
I could just before I go on I could just
come down to this um number seven has
the mult know is it seven or eight sorry
CH yeah which one you want J I'll take
either has the multiple agency
departments involved that one yeah I
think our officers have effectively
answered that one the next one which
agency Department had the lead role
we've done that as
well only at the start at the start yeah
but but perhaps you would just elaborate
because of what we've heard and we're
getting a better picture of the problems
that you you faced for for not
necessarily your own reasons but because
of outside factors
who should we say by the time we were
getting to the rough end of the deal who
had the lead role in this scenario I
mean my understanding is and I'm sure
Andre probably confirmed this that the
environment agency took the lead role on
the
prosecution and it was a case that we
had to forward all our witness
statements and evidence to the
environment agency's legal team so we
shared the cost with the the legal cost
but they took the
lead when was that can you tell me that
would have been in
2012 I
believe it the EA issued their summons
on in July
um was it
2010 oh so it's July 2010 on the
timeline confirmation from EA that they
legal team will leave the joint
prosecution so that would have been from
2010 so be their agency doing and we was
the officers Enforcement Officers did
their witness statements um there were a
number of statements and they were all
forwarded to the EA's legal team and
they took the lead right so they're a
senior Agency for one of a better phrase
yeah for that prosecution
yeah was that to cover the waste and and
all the other issues or is it with
specifically about one item the
environment agency I believe were
dealing with the tires yes it was yeah
it was various waste take on your but
they also did our okay yeah they
presented the case yes for for our
planning side of so so we've established
who who took the lead when we start
getting to the messy end of the scenario
which was the environment agency and I
think we pretty much established you
know initially all the different agen
gencies were effectively working
independently it was only subsequently
that you started working as a as a team
perhaps when you got involved into and
and not necessarily for you because you
went out to deliberately work
independently but because you all came
into areas where you were all
responsible for different aspects you
had different enforcement issues and you
were going down different roads is is
that a fair reflection or was it more
coordinated than I from sort of 06 we
were definitely sharing information um I
mean the environment agency um had to
conduct their own
investigation um and they did advise us
that their investigation would be quite
lengthy because they wanted to do um
periods of coovert surveillance because
they were interested in actually having
evidence of as many people as possible
um being you know actually visiting the
site so they set up sort of cod
surveillance to actually gather that
evidence did did they liaz with you as
as well as you appear to be leaing with
them yeah oh yes yes whenever whenever
they had some some you know activity on
their case then they would actually liaz
with us and we was regularly because we
were still chasing the compliance with
our own
notices um they were regularly uh
advising us that you know what evidence
they' um they'd witnessed when they'd
gone on the site and VI ver of
course joh um has contamination of the
water table ever been an issue at
melin's
Farm post the fire in in March this year
uh yes the environment agency uh
certainly confirmed that the the water
course and the Aquatic Life were
affected by um the the result of having
the fire so a combination of uh lee8 as
well as maybe the the rard and choose to
extinguish the F prior to that I don't
have any knowledge but simply by being
involved in that particular case I know
that's certainly true thank
you okay Council so I think we're
effectively probably up to about
question number 11 which I think coun
Mason would like to but before we
progress on should we say for the for
the more recent issues from as he said
in question 11 is there any any
questions that you want to raise up to
what we've discussed so far um just one
General one from the very beginning do
you feel that you were misled by the
land owner did he promise to carry out
actions and uh he never complied was he
deliberately lying or misleading you
from the very beginning um well obvious
I I mean my own view from looking at the
case is that we had periods of
compliance and then non-compliance
um the Mr uh fips had various planning
agents that were advising him at various
stages um and then those agents would
change for whatever reason okay it does
appear on the case that when he had a
planning agent advising him there were
periods of compliance because he was
probably and this is only my view being
advised that really he needs to comply
with the requirements of the notices um
and then there appear to be periods
where there is no agent involved and
then that's when there seems to be more
of an increase so um you know there as I
say periods of compliance and then
periods of non-compliance thank
you yes George um I've heard all
the questions and answer well there one
key uh question I would like to ask
through the whole process it appears
that you were working like um chairman
stayed separately but now at the end
have you gone back and uh modified your
processes so you can actually work more
effectively and if you have Could you
actually share those those changes with
the
committee um I mean there has I mean
I've been in post since June um and you
know since then myself and Suzanne have
done two site visits I mean there has
been no actual formal modification of
any sort of written processes but it's
certainly my Approach that you know it's
far more productive that you know the
two um bodies actually work in
conjunction with one another um and you
know we have also been in contact with
the environment agency as well um to get
updates on their position Etc um so yeah
in answer to your question no actual
formal processes have been written MH um
but we are um in the process very early
stages of actually producing um an
actual enforcement
plan uh which will set out how we will
work um to get together so so across the
three agencies yeah before before we go
any further on that we've got that
further down the
line sorry apolog it's all right George
don't worry but yeah okay good um but we
will you know elaborate on that one a
little bit further because I think this
is something that we we have already
highlighted ourselves so we will expand
on that a little bit further down the
line if that's okay Chris yeah so just
to enlarge on what you said you said
you've got you're coming out of an
enforcement plan for three OES to work
together is this in relation to this
particular site or in general no the the
whole approach of the enforcement team
for how it deals with breaches of
planning control so it's clear so we
have a plan in place that sets out how
we will deal with breaches um so
everybody's clear in the public Parish
councils Etc what the enforcement team
actually um how it operates and what it
would consider to be serious breaches
and minor breaches okay thank you I am
aware that as the chairman said earlier
there are hundreds several hundred um
Enforcement cases always ongoing in
rodford yes
I I don't know whether whether you have
a a list in your head of which is the
the one likely to cause the most trouble
whether this is the one where is one in
your head right now that you're talking
to your to your is about the future but
are you feeling more confident that that
if we get something on a similar scale
we're more likely and we in the general
sense are more likely to be able to head
it off and deal with it could can can
can we hold that for a second and we
come we will come back to it it is
further down the list
and we will definitely come back to it
but can we just progress with with these
ones but no I know it's it's there it's
this is where do we go after this is I
think John you were quite interested in
this question 11 if you'd like to yes
okay about the August to April what
happened okay um well you you've seen
the question so I'm just going to trot
it out and then I'm going to ask you
another question because I read the
timeline a bit further and another
questions occurred to me um question 11
actually is about was any action taken
between August 2007 and April 2008 and
in
particular uh August 2007 talks about a
site
visit
um where Rubble was viewed being
delivered to the site aerial photographs
showing an amount of waste had increased
since 2003 and not
reduced and then in April 2008 the the
environment agency successfully
prosecuted two men there were two
relevant men uh for burning waste
materials at the site so the question in
this first part is what happened
between 2007
2008 yeah okay I can answer that um
there is an additional uh point which I
found uh within the files that in
February 2008 um we had contact from
Essex police to say that they were
carrying out their own investigation on
the site I'm not quite sure what the
details of that were um but they advised
that they would be going down to the
site and would we like to join them on a
joint visit which we did do with the
environment agency so there was a
further visit done in February 2008 but
I think what what is more relevant at
this period is that the enforcement team
uh was dealing with another case within
the district um which was again a waste
related matter um and that was actually
causing um considerable harm and um we
had two public inquiries and follow on
court cases in relation to that um so
and that was happening in that time
frame so that would have t and I know
for a fact that um that took up a lot of
um in that took two
officers uh time to actually deal with
and both of those officers were the
officers that were dealing with Mitchell
in
far I want to continue because um I've
been I've been desperately trying to
read this timeline for a particular word
or called
burning and uh burning only seems to get
picked up in April
2008 and then July
2008 and
then December 2008 January
2009 when when clearly the risk uh on
the site had clearly increased
significantly but it certainly would
have drawn my attention to it I guess
I'm going to ask the awkward question
and I know you don't want to speculate
but you can give an
opinion and the opinion I'd like you to
give anyone who care to to give it is
given the
sets of circumstances where the risk
assessment had increased so so
dramatically to include burning could
this event in
201 14 14 14 um could that have been
foreseen
because there was that was the first
evidence of burning it doesn't take too
much extrapolation to consider you know
how far that risk could go so opinions
please
sure
uh within the um time span of the the
timeline that that I managed to
establish from uh the uh the the records
that we have uh the the first
involvement we had in something relevant
to the discussions today for the site
was in May
2005 um from that I have eight separate
records of of instances relating to the
site the eth included in the fire in
March this year
um there is a big gap between September
2006 and April 2010 where there is no
record of any complaint or any reference
to um uh additional observations of
smoke from the site in fact most of the
observations made um from motorists who
observed the smoke and called in they
may some were local residents some
weren't but they were generally
motorists um we have one instance in
January 14 where police reported smoke
across the
carriageway uh and we had an instance in
2012 where the fire and police services
had attended two simultaneous fires on
the site um one wood and one rubbish was
I was described at the time with the
environment agency being the lead
Authority for Waste matters
inappropriate um treatment of waste
already burning it would have been one
of the offenses that they would have
been progressing and investigating as
well yes it's fair to say there were
clearly the instances of burning on the
site prior to March 2015 with the
significant tii that did occur um but
not anything in great volume such as
came through through our
team not
to were aware of the obviously the the
the prosecution and the environment
agency were very open about their
investigations as well there was
information sharing but it's uh really
quite Limited in nature in terms of
burning reports that we receive directly
sorry Martin I over spoke you there and
apologize for doing that you finished um
so in your so summing up from what
you're saying um I get the impression
you're saying that in your opinion it
couldn't have been
foreseen
the very specific nature of of the
incident in March I think consum burning
would have happened on occasions in
terms of the scale of the incident that
happened there um I I I couldn't
speculate as to to whether the
environment agency would have thought
that was likely um but uh I think we can
assume that fires would continue on site
yes but not not necessarily on the scale
that that came to be
anybody else want to contribute to that
no I don't mean us I mean our our
visitors any thoughts any
opinion
um well I know that we did receive uh a
call
from uh the fire service in 2008 I think
at a time when they had attended Three
Fires in one
week um and L those details will pass
through to the EA um the environment
agency
um I can't you know I can't really
answer for what the thoughts were of the
officers that were dealing with it on
the time you know at the time I I know
that's probably not what you want to
hear but
um I think with any site um there's
always an element of of risk but um you
know
as to how you um deal with that um I
mean I think that we were doing what we
thought was um required to to deal with
the breaches I mean at the at the time
when we received this call uh we were in
that process of working with the EA to
formulate this joint prosecution
um so um yeah I think
yeah I can't really give you the answer
okay it was an awkward question I've got
another one as
well I'll come back hindsight is a
wonderful thing it is indeed yes
um and obviously we've all learned from
this do you think that given a similar
situation and a you know a progression
of small fires small fires small
fires you would look at this or the
environment agency whoever is the lead
Budd would look at this scenario
differently because of what you've
learned from the past
experiences I think any agency uh
including like Rochford would be you
know you learn from past experience and
sometimes you know obviously an event
such as this offers an ideal opportunity
to reflect on how you've dealt with
things in the past so um I would imagine
that as a result of the disruption that
was caused um with the fire um I should
imagine that all bodies are now
reflecting on how they would actually
deal with matters of waste storage night
chairman could we just before we leave
that yeah I mean I think Robin's got one
to come as well the particular interest
I have is is is asking the environment
agency you couldn't be here I think
that's a polite way of putting it could
we um find a way of writing to them and
de and asking this question of risk
assessment and the extent to which those
risk assessments could have led to you
know a better um exp yeah yeah no I
don't have a problem with that at all
John if we can Aras it certainly will
thank you thank you chairman I'd be
interested to know a little bit more
about the cause of the fire that's all
of the fires or the reason for the fires
particularly the one in March 2005 15
was it simply a case of the burning of
the waste that got out of control in
March 2015 are you able to because you I
think the safest thing it I don't think
that was determined certainly the police
didn't get very far with with the
interviews that they did carry out um
and I don't think they established
whether we're looking at uh whether the
fire was even deliberate to start
with
interesting I believe the fire started
in the early hours of the morning is
that right around 3: to 4: a.m. in the
morning no I I attended on the the
Monday night at about 10:00 I understand
the fire started approximately 90
minutes before that oh so um it
was it was well aligned to at the point
that I attended but um yet it was I
believe it started after after the
Working Day and finished on Monday thank
you if I can just add something to pick
up on your point councelor Mason um in
the response that we had from the
environment agency about tonight's
meeting they have said in the last
paragraph and I quote we have been doing
a lot of work on waste site fire risk in
the last year but the initial Focus has
been on active permitted high-risk waste
sites
so you know environment agency are
actually um looking at high risk fire
yeah High sites with high risk of fire
so so I suspect that that is perhaps as
a result of melin's
f May comment that certainly the the
fire service as well um uh alongside an
industry body for for Waste Management
uh are also looking at revising their
guidance because of the current
phenomenon of of of waste fires that are
happening there at least one a day of of
significance across the country uh and
in terms of reducing the burden the
bading the waste was industry has across
all waste material types uh
unfortunately guidance tends to end up
being used obviously by regulated sites
legitimate sites of which clearly this
this wasn't one um but they are looking
at that but also the tactics and
suppressant that can be used by the fire
service to extinguish such fires as well
and to do so in a in a more efficient
and timey
manner is there still waste on the site
yes
y
and then George and move on it's PR a
question about
um what you can do I mean I don't know I
like the answer if it help me it's
probably nothing at all but um when you
get a site not just this one but any
site that raises a risk looks as it
could be tires or anything oil fuel or
anything if you get a site that's got a
risk do you have anything in place or
should you have I don't know legally or
otherwise to take possession of that
site in other words you take control and
you might have to remove Goods but you
have some form of control you just let
it sit there and get bigger and bigger
and bigger is there a cut off point
where you have or legisl I don't know
that's what I'm asking is there a cut
off point where you say enough's enough
you move in deal with it to reduce the
risk is there anything like that we do
have powers they're called like direct
action powers where the council can
actually um go onto the site and Carry
Out Works to actually clear the site yes
we do we didn't think it was necessary
on this side got you was the other yeah
but obviously that's that is normally a
course of action we take after we've
served an enforcement notice and
we've
prosecuted um it's we go there's like a
formal process that we follow uh
negotiation um serving the notice
monitoring compliance with the notice
the notice then isn't if it's not
complied with we' then got the option to
prosecute which is obviously the route
that we've taken with Mr
fips um and this site um and then yeah
obviously then we do have the option to
take direct action um but I mean I don't
I'm I haven't been involved in any
discussion of that sort of action before
you don't worry too much because we're
going to cover this I think in in the
plan that we have for the future which I
think uh Chris has touched on and and
Robin so I think we we will elaborate on
what you have in place for for the
future um otherwise we're going to be
jumping up to question 19 I think and
we've still got a few George have you
got something on this no answer um we've
still got two questions predominantly
outstanding on on on your area which is
one are there any enforcement notices
still
outstanding uh yes there
are yes um uh we've got two enforcement
notices um that the requirements haven't
been complied with however we've had a
discussion this evening prior to this
meeting um about whether or not we can
actually revisit those actual notices
because of uh a court order that was
issued by the courts uh and it's
something that um we need to look into
further uh on a legal
basis one check if I may there a
question s you just led me into there
really is that I notice he got
prosecuted £15,000 and then there were
costs and and I've known in the past
where people which he did he went to
prison for non payment of fines was this
fine written off of that prison hang on
no you're jumping again
J just triggered me up yeah I
know otherwise we lose where we going um
I think it's question 15 J sorry that's
okay
um but yes there are and and this we
obviously what you're looking at now is
going to be very much in in line with
the plan that you're going to have as a
future line of of operation which we
hopefully will cover in a little while
um I think the last one actually
probably comes down to you Martin um
where it says the last site visit was in
August what hazards were identified and
is there any further risk of further
inance at this
site
the last s visit in in August was was
undertaken by my colleagues here rather
than myself uh I I've come to understand
that there was another fire in August um
but again there was no direct contact to
to us about that from from any party um
uh in terms of having seen the site yes
uh there remain tires on site both the
um unburnt and burnt remnants from the
original pile that caught in in March uh
and and then there was a separate um uh
collection of bailed tires which were a
bit deeper into the site but still on
the side where the railway embankment is
uh and and I
think Ivon will be able to tell you more
about the other types of waste scattered
across the site um and deeper in but in
terms of tire fire yes but there isn't
the material on site for anything to be
of the scale that we saw in March much
fewer tires in specifically uh than than
were a light in March um still going to
be significant don't get me wrong but
but not at that same scale uh I wouldn't
like to give a percentage difference um
but uh but
significant right I pass it twice a day
so I know there's still a lot of tires
there you did say that you would um if
the person was prosecuted you would go
and remove the contaminated
waste like tires um why haven't you done
it now then Mr fips has been prosecuted
there s risk of fire from the must be at
least a th000 tires there and why
haven't you removed that so you can
eliminate the risk I wasn't aware that
we'd agreed to do anything well I
thought you just said that um if if um
right yeah you would remove the
contaminant that would cause the fire in
the place we have the power to take
direct action but uh Mr chairman
actually wanted to cover that later yeah
I mean this is what we're going to look
for is no is to to see you know we've
High basically up until now we've
highlighted the issues that were have
led up to the far in 2015 etc etc what
we're hoping for in the second part
butly is where do we go from here how
can we make sure we don't go down this
road the last question
come it is to make make the point s of
finish the the answer right we we'll
touch on on the point for later the the
Environ environment agency do have the
authority to move waste where it's
polluting a water course all right my
understanding is that they did move some
of the remnants of the tire fire from
March in order to stop or prevent any
further contamination of the water
course as a result of the fire I did so
they did so at that time I did I'm
trying to find some pictures I did cuz I
pass it every day in the train twice a
day yeah I tried to take some pictures
but I can't find them but there is a
considerate amount of tires um partially
burnt um a lot burnt dust near the near
the railway line still I would have
thought as a precaution you would have
moved them further wrong so even if it
did cast fire it wouldn't contaminate
the railway in any way but hey
if it helps and I've been very
quiet apologies for
late to to to your meeting I did
actually have a conference call on this
on this very issue with the the
environment agency who did as as uh as
Martin has said uh make arrangements for
uh some of the burnt materials to be
moved into a better location in their
view on the site that was as far as they
were prepared to go though in terms of
uh
expenditure uh in in order to make the
site and the the water courses uh around
the site safe from uh from contamination
and uh I I mention I mentioned cost
because that was that was a a discussion
with with the environment agency in
terms of the resources that they had
available to uh take uh remedial
remedial action on the site and and I
think probably uh that is is an issue to
come back to when you get to uh yeah uh
the question in in in uh in the second
group because I think that's relevant to
your deliberations in relation to the
the discussion about direct action I
think um we we' Bally got to the point
um where we've said what import action
why did it take so long I think you
pretty much highlighted why it's taken
so long and I you know while I I know
that we've sort of said attendees group
one and attendees group two um you know
you may continue to be able to offer
give some support for should we say the
the second half of the questioning but
up until now thank you very much I think
your honesty has been quite refreshing
from some of the other areas we've uh
had answers in the past so thank you
very much um we if I may take comfort
break you certainly if anybody else
wants to have five minutes we both for
five
and get 25
p
on this on about four occasions now um
which I think is probably question 17
and and I think first everybody's
touched on this if we start off on that
and then we can spin the other questions
off the back of it um as it says there I
mean I'll kick it off has a strategy
being drawn up by the counsil and other
agencies to avoid another another
instant at this
side
um who would like to to respond to to
that question well you looking very poly
at me am I yes well let's start off with
you um well at this moment no uh there
hasn't been but obviously uh one of the
things that uh you know with with
everything that's gone on and all the
conversations we've had looking at
everything I think it's going to be
essential to draw something together um
so that we actually do have a relevant
plan of action when something does come
along um looking back over the history
which has shocked me to be honest um but
also understanding that history in as
much as the the courts to some extent
whereby you can see that there's been
abuse of process that's coming quite a
few times where Mr fips has used that uh
because you know there's been processes
that have been out of syn it would seem
and um this this has been a major
problem that that has actually found all
uh
authorities a problem because they've
had to be so careful in how they
structured their process now I've been
uh I I downloaded the EA um booklet the
new one which which gives a whole line
of processes that have to be ticked off
that you have to do this and you have to
do that and you have to do that before
you can actually really get to anything
so you know I guess it it's it's been
the same the whole way along for our
officers whereby they've had to go
through these processes all the time and
then when it gets to the courts you know
something comes up it's uh it's out of
syn and especially where both um essics
and
ourselves had this problem where all of
a sudden where they're working in tand
and then the two different cases come up
and all of a sudden the essics one is
now given an extension of a year and now
everything is out of sync so you know
even though they were working together
and and this was the interesting
conversation that you know I've had they
were actually working together but the
act the process was now out of sync and
and I think you know uh that that's been
the main
problem I mean obviously other people
but even you you started to elaborate on
what you were trying do for the future a
plan a form of action um I guess with
Susan perhaps you'd like to elaborate
now and then colleagues can can sort of
bring their questions in that they
started to to load into you earlier on
so perhaps if you go back to where you
were qu of an hour ago and yeah and
replay I mean what I think I I mentioned
earlier was the fact that um there's
there's two issues here or two matters
here is one one that as a an enforcement
team we're looking at developing a
enforcement plan which clearly sets out
how we will deal with all breaches of
planning control how we will prioritize
them how we will investigate what powers
we have um you know whether or not uh
this issue of expediency about taking
action Etc but I also think um in
reference to this particular case and
the lessons that you know we've learned
from this case is that um you know we
need to have a clear um strategy of if
you know another instance I mean we
Suzanne and I are working on another
case together at the present moment and
um you know if we had a strategy in
place that you know what we would do I
mean we we're we're discussing it as
we're going along we're already saying
that we're both going to take
potentially take action on this other
site
and let's serve our enforcement notices
at the same time um so that um you know
it's a two ProMed effect if you like
from both
authorities um so I think if we
actually Drew something up on that basis
that if there are two um parties
involved that we actually um you know
get together early on in the
investigation and actually uh work
towards a a joint uh not attack but a
joint approach stry yeah joint strategy
okay well I know there's going to be a
plenty of questions John then Chris then
we'll work back yeah can I I want to go
back to what Ian told me or told us
about this new booklet from the EA it
sounded to me as you were not terribly
happy with the a a long process which
seemed would seem to me wouldn't be very
helpful to getting early resolution of
these sort of issues and maybe I'll
start with that question chairman I've
got another one to follow on is is that
a you know is it a new procedure um and
and does it in your opinion slow things
down
um it's a new procedure whether it slows
things down I don't know I I don't think
it's been tested I think it's only come
out uh April this month uh this year so
it's it's a new procedure that's gone in
um and I was having a you know a look
through all the various things there are
various other acts that are included in
this new booklet but it has got the new
items in there and and the various
things that the various guidance that
that is actually the EA have put forward
in how they will approach a problem so I
don't know if it's been tested as yet I
have no knowledge of it I've only just
got sight of that booklet because
because I was now wanting to research to
see what other avenues do we have um
with ourselves uh and of course you know
we um our own officers are are working
in tandem with essics you know literally
trying to formulate something because at
this moment they're working on something
they're going to be looking I guess at
how they work that procedure and then
use that information that they get as
they're moving along to formulate
something and I think that's that's the
only way that that we can look at going
forward we can look at the guidance that
is offered you know from EA and the way
that they are producing things and I
guess uh you're probably more familiar
with this new guidance um great not
you're not actually haven't seen that
chairman I think we need we need that
yeah um to to include it as part of our
review yeah in in order that we can make
a judgment upon it and because we can
have opinions um and also it will help
obviously inform eics and um Rood
enforcements as to whether you know that
gives a relevance the to where to go but
Ian put his um his finger right right on
the button by saying clearly the action
we take next is about putting it right
and putting it right quickly what I
can't quite understand is if if the
courts have got out of line with regard
to the various actions is there not a
procedure where you can go back to that
court and say look look what has
happened we want to ensure that it
doesn't happen again we need to progress
this the decisions you've made need to
be reviewed so is there any sort of
mechanism that we can take it we being
the collective and collaborative way
take it back to court and therefore um
redress the balance I I guess that is
very much um a legal question um which
which goes to how uh any appeal uh
actually is processed and the way in
which they obviously look at things in a
silo they don't look at anything that's
that's coming along they only look at
the actual issue that is is there in
front of them and maybe Angela could if
I make
um Council Mason you you made reference
to the courts now um just to clarify
there was a difference between the
enforcement notices and the appeals at
planning inspectorate stage and I think
that's where Suzanne was it saying that
different planning inspectors gave
different timelines to enforcement with
regards to the the prosecution and the
court action that was a joint yes effort
with a um envirment agency and there was
no there wasn't an issue there with
regards having to go back and say this
is not it's not in keeping with that
because that that is a separate
jurisdiction alog together so there's a
difference between the planning
inspectorate and the actual Court as in
the criminal courts and magistrates
courts Crown courts so thank you that's
very helpful because it helps me focus
on the next point that say well surely
we can go back to the planning
inspectorate the chief executive of the
planning inspectorate and point out the
error of their ways and ask
for yes
I Delight him being Popular by asking
question can I just make a pointy me I
mean I think what what I think the point
that yvon's making about looking to see
in a a more holistic way if I can use
that word uh you know from now on in
about how we can uh work with uh you
know the County Council that is relevant
or the environment agency in in uh on on
on uh on dealing with particular issues
issues is is is a very good one but I
don't think we should lose sight of the
fact that you know one of the challenges
that that we faced with this particular
site was as you've heard you know things
started things started in a small way
there were particular
circumstances behind the uh the uh the
aims of the of of the landowner
initially for example in bringing tires
onto the site because he had another
company that he thought could actually
use those tires for a particular purpose
and hey L we'll bring them on here and
then they'll move off and and all will
be well over period of time it was
apparent that that wasn't that that
wasn't going to happen um and uh and
then I think there was probably a main
chance uh spotted Luke it costs a lot
for for companies who uh have tires to
dispose of to put them in in landfill
that's a particular cost Luke actually
uh I'll put my hand up you know bring
them on my site and I'll charge you a
lot less and all of a sudden
uh you know companies are bringing tires
to him and he's uh he's pocketing the
cash and off he's going so there was a
sort of change in in the uh the way that
the site was viewed over a period of
time Rochford at particular point in
time said hey luk we've got to serve
enforcement notices and take action and
then later on as things developed uh you
know the County Council came on board
then the environment agency was involved
and and you know you've got these
different uh processes going on with
different timelines so it would be
brilliant if in a particular
circumstances depending on the uh on the
uh on the site it was possible to have
this sort of you know direct coordinated
approach but you know it it may not be
the case that it's possible to do that
because you've actually got sort of
incremental changes over a period of
time and you're trying to take action as
as early as possible and and and uh and
resolve resolve the issue and that's
then developing uh o o over over a
period so you know there was substantial
changes in the way that the site uh
developed over time and the way that the
enforcement action and the environment
agency and so on were were involved and
and I think it's important just to to to
you know to be aware of that of of that
of that change thank you I I mean I've
got a few questions both toon and
Suzanne that I would like to put later
but Chris you you you were touting on
this subject so on so back here yes I I
think circling around it here in
said Ian you said about you've been
looking for for new avenues i' like to
know have you found any yet no okay no
you know I mean again
um where we are at this moment we're
looking at a situation which has been as
Sean quite rightly said it's been a
combination of so many different things
that have come in where there's been an
enforcement for for one reason and it's
grown into enforcement for other reason
reasons that have just been added on um
some have been satisfied some haven't um
so it's been an ongoing thing I I think
realistically if we're going to be
looking for new avenues and
investigating where we go forward I I
think it really is a case as as is now
where we have an issue where both uh
Suzanne and Ivon are dealing jointly
with an issue going forward um looking
at it and I and I would guess that if
there is something else that is flagged
up it would come up to Martin to bring
him on board with that which would then
be a notification to EA to let them know
just a flag up I would guess that you
know there is something here are you
interested in it does this come into
your remit so it just keeps them
informed and I I would I would assume
that what we would be looking at is a
Formula going forward something we can
can actually set down that when we do
get a situation we can actually start to
action it in a logical way
okay I I I I've I've been aware for a
long time that we have a lot of
Enforcement cases outstanding and I
think it was said that we we were second
of the country behind Burman Enforcement
cases outstanding and that's obviously
shows the workload that offices are
under the problems they've got and it
also shows that we are a little bit
different to other districts
however there are other districts out
there and surely there is best practice
from
from two tier Council systems elsewhere
in the country on the other other
councils we can look at as examples of
best practice to see what we can learn
from are you referring to
resources well in because obviously I
mean the first question you've asked is
cases
outstanding um so uh you you would be
aware that mean obviously we we have a
resource issue yeah which needs to be
addressed um as you know uh we are in
the in the present you know we're
looking at a new assessment we've got uh
a new member of Staff a new ad who will
be coming into post uh mid this month um
who actually specializes in enforcement
and has got a tremendous reputation for
that so again again it it's looking at
when she comes into post I I would be
expecting her to be looking at all the
Avenues that um are within her remit you
know to address those various problems
so again this would be within the whole
G I I I mentioned the the enforc number
cases to show that we are different
we've got a a greater problem than most
other councils of the country however
the point I wanted to make was we are
not the only counsel of the country um
there only to invent the wheel every
time is there not some good practice
elsewhere in the UK we can look at and
and see what we can learn from um i'
just like to
ask was mentioned I think in passing
earlier that ver many houses near the
site it's a bit bit remote well in a
sense that's true although once you get
a fire and prevailing wind takes it uh
northeastwards um I was down in the
Night by the car's arms and the houses
along the RO and a very evil Nast as if
you were down there you notice how evil
looking Sky out was so so it does affect
people but also the water course concern
because you know you got you got water
courses down Downstream I'm very worried
about and you mentioned I could ask
Martin you mentioned earlier about water
contamination yes are we still
monitoring
that no I certainly the the local
Authority didn't monitor that it was the
environment agency as it
um pollution of water courses uh that's
something they do relatively routinely
anyway as a monitoring would it be
possible to check them back see if they
are monitoring it I can
certainly whether there is further data
could it come back please to the toie
committee thank you you on the L thank
youman I mean on the latter Point
actually I don't believe the infirmity
see are continue to monitor I think they
monitored it for a period of time after
the incident and then we satisfied that
there was no uh undue uh uh difficulties
with the uh the the water quality um so
you know I think they they took the view
then that there was no uh need for uh
ongoing regular uh regular monting
whether they come back you know at
yearly intervals or not I don't know and
it maybe that asking that question would
be useful I I would like it CU I'm
delighted satisfied but you know the the
second Point chairman if I mean is go
back to the the the issue about best
practice the answer to that is yes
because uh off regularly attend meetings
with colleagues from uh uh other
authorities uh in in in Essex and uh and
also attend uh other uh Gatherings of uh
enforcement officers uh from from other
parts of the country to talk about uh
cases and best practice and changes in
legislation and so on what what have I
gleaned from that uh well much of the uh
the the processes and procedures that we
follow are based are based I would say
chairman are B are based on on best
practice uh okay thank you can can I
just make just clarify Martin will you
excuse me will you make sure that we ask
the environment agency what their view
is on current potential contamination to
to water courses and also what period of
inspection they've done up to and what
is their period of routine inspection
okay and come back to us on on this
issue okay George and Robin just
the all right chairman and we talking
about water courses and the environment
agency are responsible for the
monitoring of that but what about the
water table are they responsible for
that as well or is that a separate
thing I
think I'm not entirely sure on the
definition of what controlled Waters I
would have to ask that question as
well believe controlled Waters is just
running water as as such rather than the
table itself um but
groundwaters I'm not sure where that
would fall so yeah I will clarify thank
you okay can can I I'll ask the ladies a
question now that I've got down here you
talked about this joint strategy that
you're working on you're working
together and by and large you're almost
developing it as you go go along you
made
earlier have you got a timeline for for
how you expect to have have a joint plan
put in place are we saying well by the
middle of next year we will have a a
joined up plan of process and this is
what it will be uh you know this is how
our strategy will be or is it going to
be u a more protracted view or or is it
going to be done in 3 months I don't
know um I think when I was uh advising
um the room about the strategy that
suzan and myself for working on at the
present moment I I think I sort of
indicated that it was on a almost an
informal MH basis at the present moment
um it's the way that we've decided to
work together on this next case that
we're dealing with um so but um I mean
I've made a note here that it you know
it's sensible to have something
formalized um well yeah I mean my my
view but it's not something that ladies
May getting very well but one of you may
decide I don't want to do this anymore
yes that's it but at this current moment
in time it's it's something that you
know we're tending to do off of our own
backs and nothing no formal procedur has
been put in place but it well perhaps we
could suggest that in conjunction with
sha or or Ian there is some sort of
formal structure put in place so that we
can get a joint approach to this and we
don't end up operating because seon
decides to go somewhere else that whole
issue falls down the pan again and and
we're back to where we were in
2006 so perhaps I can leave that one
with you or or that's noted chair okay
any more issues we want to talk about
about
future areas and we then move on to some
of the other questions that we we've
still got here for
example George you'd like to go you you
like money you go to number
yeah with regards to Mr Phillips uh uh
binds uh do you in your opinion believe
that the the fines represent a clear
representation obviously is in
imprisonment on how we and how do we
recoup the money back to uh the uh the
council chairman if I may the the fines
were set in accordance with um the um
the legislation and um on the scale um
and that is set down by the judge of the
case now um as far as the fines written
off well that's not I can confirm the
fines were not written off they weren't
they weren't written off uh the actually
for once the court did the work for us
and chased the fines they took their
money first then they paid us the rest
which was cost to ask that yeah of the
costs we received all the costs of which
we took U out share which amounted to
Circa £
6,123 the rest cuz the environmental
agency what the lead agency they
incurred more costs on that front they
the rest went to them and we f it on to
them
go following the same issue three legal
ignorance on my part I would like to ask
the questions um we're coming up to 16
it's really we haven't got to the
question 16
16 is about what this has cost the
agency and especially L District Council
but what's it cost and all the costs I'm
talking about our material costs and I'm
not talking about the prosecution cost
but what it's cost us for labor for all
the inquiries all the all the issues
that have been put into it could we make
a claim against this a legal claim for a
civil claim for that
cost
and if you failed to pay that would we
be in a position but you've already
answered part of the question but would
be be in a position to go for a
bankruptcy if he failed to pay or they
didn't have the main chairman I'm not
aware that when um where Ivon and suzan
carrying out their statute duties and
and investigating and and that they we
can go and seek back our cost on that
part the cost where we're taking formal
action down prosecution rout and those
costs that bill of cost that we would
have produced in CT would have included
officers time in giving witness
statements from that point onwards but
prior to that when they're
investigating I'm not I've never seen
the case I'm not aware of a case and I
don't think we can go back and say you
owe us this for all the offic time spent
over the years I don't think there's a
possibility well gentl we we look like
we're almost on on the home straight
here because well we might not be
because question 18 is do we have any
other sites like this one in the
district but it seems to me that we do
because you've already mentioned that
you're working together on another
project so should we be looking for
alarm bells ringing shortly I mean the
uniqueness of Mitchell's Farm is the
size of the site um but yeah we do have
other sites in the district where there
is uh the
importation where it appears that there
is the importation of waste occurring on
the site
um yeah we have we have a a c and and
and can I ask the question is it is it
just essics and rord that deal with this
or the environment agency involved as
well is a build of another big issue one
particular case that we've been
referring to um this evening um Suzanne
and I are working together on and the
environment agency suzan you've been
advising the environment agency um to
get their intelligence about some of the
activities on the site are are you happy
with with the way this is working I
mean has everybody learn including the
environment agency in particular learned
from I can't answer for the environment
agenc well from your from your end of
the situation are they are they being
supportive responsive or whatever phrase
you want to
use I think the difficulty is with
environment agency they have permits and
exemptions so someone could have an
exemption for a site and be able to
import a certain amount of waste under
that
exemption we then have to prove that
they're not working with that within
that exemption so initially the first
part for the environment agency would be
to establish if it's over and above what
is included in their
exemption so you're almost operating
with your hand tied behind your back
well we're looking at the the we're
looking at the Planet Side the land so
therefore we consider there's a breach
of planning control it would be down to
the environment agent to to establish if
it is waste would that that be the best
way to put it or whether it's something
to do with
agricultureal so that's why together we
know there's breach planning control and
we need to
establish because they are allowed a
certain amount of waste within an
agricultural holding for
works and then it could be something
that could be I don't want to give too
much detail under agricultural permitted
development and that's where the
environment agency would come in are
they within their exemption or permit or
are they
not that structure for exemptions and
permits for Waste stretches to fires as
well right so you can be Exempted for a
certain volume of material that's
burned
yeahor Martin just a question you you
rais your point about exemptions is
there different categorizations of
exemptions where um which will actually
help our officers to try and uh mitigate
some of these issues they're facing I I
believe that the the the exemp
uh for for burning stretches only to
agricultural use um there's only one
tier as far as I'm aware just one tier
I'm not sure that it's of any assistance
to anyone
particularly the very fact that someone
may be to burn and abuse that process
youed commers um it wouldn't wouldn't
assist an enforcement agency when trying
to determine what's what's legitimate
and what's not I think the question I'm
trying to ask is is that uh
the there's different
restrictions which is is causing you to
not function properly as officers
because of uh the EA and I would like to
actually understand what those
restrictions are and how they're
defined or how can we actually
understand how we can operate within
those restrictions to help you I I don't
know if I answer the question I think
the concern we have is that we would
like to be able to support you in any
way we could so that we don't have a
Michelin too it's as simple as that um
if there's something we can recommend
from this committee that will help you
to be in a better position to to fight
your corner or fight your Co well then
tell us and we will try and make the
recommendations yeah through through the
appropriate channels um
but at the moment it does seem that you
know the environment
agency again seems to be the the
lead person on this with with these uh
different allowances etc etc um but
please I think even after this meeting
if there are areas that you feel you can
obviously you can talk to Ian and sha or
if you feel that perhaps there is an
area that the Review Committee could
make recommend ation or you R we would
gladly but we do not basically want to
walk into a melin's to if we could have
avoided by doing something I think
that's the Jack thank you it's a general
thing really um there a question of us
really is why isn't the environment
agency here because I mean all this is
going backwards and forward we keep
being the environment agency we' got no
one to ask into the questions you're
asking really but also is it cuz I've
never been to miss I've driven past did
many times but I've never is it worth of
site visit when we adjudicate and think
about what we're talking now and the
other thing was I know for a fact that
from this um this our
Council go
on
been the officers have always had to go
down with
police
not don't want to go don't go I'll go to
ask a question just take a train from ra
to the station and you can see it
perfectly gole it's high up I don't I
don't think at the moment there is
anything to be achieved by having s bu I
think I think we pretty much establish
we
know the last thing I wanted to say was
that I'm aware that we've not found one
ripper in this thing and um with the you
know with the powers of investigation
that R um why haven't we all this why
haven't we done something for but we've
already had it established earlier on
that the environment agency did use
cover stuff we haven't got access to
that have we we did they they were
supplying the information they were
supplying the information to Evon and
Suzanne but earlier on we talking about
you're talking about the different types
of waste just a few moments ago we could
we had to establish this was going in or
that was going in surely cameras or
something would have told you what sort
of vehicles are driving in if they're
big smaller can I just jump in
here Ripper can only be used if it will
result in imprisonment of over 6 months
and I don't think there's any planning
regulation that it could
breach if so you can't use cameras on
plan but but we did we did did establish
that along quite early on that the
environment agency had used covert
systems and had worked with the other
other agencies to produce the legal case
in 200 six they started well they
started it and and the case that went
to EA fored RDC a batch of photographs
taken on recent visit etc etc in 2008 so
the the the the photographs were being
taken by the environment agency they
they had the authority to do it and they
did it and they did share
them I think some of those photographs
were taken from the air weren't they by
helicopter Rochford actually
commissioned um aerial photographs of
the
site just quick uh just a legal
question um with the site with the
pollution have we had any claims against
the council with regards to the fire no
not that I'm
aware I would um are we
covered is the council
covered for a scenario of that well F on
from what your officers have been
working on and then then given the um
the timeline I think we are covered we
we've done everything we can under the
legislation within our powers um the
course I I I I can't see how we can't be
covered but you
know s you asking in terms of the the
effects the effects of the fire and also
the contamination of the water um uh
with regards to the population around
the area if they've been affected maybe
in a year's time they could come back
and claim back to against Council I'm
just being U thinking out of the box at
the moment and I'm just trying
understand if we've got any
cover from well we do have insurance
as thought the issue here is is you know
the you know wasn't the council that
that that that started the fire and so
therefore you know if there was an issue
that emerged from that I would have
thought it would be a recourse against
the uh against the the land but I think
what George is really inferring really
is have we got anything to worry about
in terms of We Were in our procedure
that would have made us liable for any
recklessness Tim I I don't believe we
were LAX in the procedure and certainly
as far as the fire was concerned I think
you you've heard that Martin was was at
that you know and the environment agency
were were heavily involved so I don't
think there was any laxity in the
procedures that the council uh the
environment agency or or others followed
in dealing with the uh the incident in
in in in March okay if I may speak just
to alleviate fears in terms of the air
quality there public health England did
um send out their air quality cell to
monitor it two locations as the fire
moved around the plume Sor as it move
around resulting from the fire which
didn't give rise to any concern in
relation to air pollution um once it had
grounded obviously you know clearly
there are pollutants going up but in
terms of dilution dispersal
but it's fine thanks Mar ladies and
gentlemen are there any further
questions that you want to ask our our
visitors this evening in relation to
this have we have we asked question
19 I think we I think we covered that
but what did we get a view of could we
well there is question 19 if if anybody
would like to to answer that would we
have taken would it have been better if
we take direct action to the site uh
when the court process first
started if I me you know I think my my
my view on this is that it's appropriate
for the council to follow all of the
relevant uh procedures and direct action
I think is is very much a last resort um
you know and uh uh in the normal course
of events I think one would have
anticipated uh that um uh you know the
the process of taking someone to court
and actually uh you know in the end uh
Mr fips was locked up you know one would
not have envisioned
that uh the situation would have got to
to the stage it did the experience is
that um long before in the majority of
cases long before that sort of situation
arises uh you know it's possible to
reach a a res a resolution so you know I
think uh this very very much is uh is a
site that um obiously it's it's it's a
one-off but I think it probably is as as
as oneoff as you you're going to get in
terms of uh not just you know the the
whole process of of the the enforcement
Pro uh procedures the the number of uh
organizations and agencies involved in
that process and and ultimately the end
result that you know fines were levied
by the court um and uh you know the uh
the owner was was was then was then was
then actually actually locked up and
still we didn't get a a resolution
ultimately to to to the problem so but I
think direct action is very much a last
a last
resort anything else anybody just a
question here where are we now I mean
where where we going with this now I
mean what's the forecast for well the
question is now is is have we got any
more questions for our visitors then
we'll we can have 10 minutes
we
Chris yeah just going to just going to
add uh on where we are now because no
one has asked where we are now that's
what we're going to yeah but we are we
are no but no where we are now with
richond at this at this moment in time
well we were given guidance we had to be
a bit careful as to how we
addressed that scenario I mean we we
have um we've identified the issues in
August mhm and the scenario is there we
talked about that
um I I I say I think we were given the
guidance we have to be careful Paul
might be able to elaborate on this on
what we we asked on the immediate
dealings with farm and and the action
that we will be taken or can be taken or
is being taken perhaps you can elaborate
a little bit on that but without being
well I think Ian's got something else
rather than anything to do with the
council doing anything can we interest
yeah I I don't yeah I I think the the
risk is here that this is in public and
okay we've only got one member the
public actually here but nevertheless
it's in public and therefore will be
recorded and therefore be made available
to the public so the issue is is
anything we're going to say now about
how this is going to be dealt with going
to Prejudice that situation and should
we not go into exempt session for for it
I agree with councel Mason angel can I
don't know where we go as say I none of
us know what Ian wants to say I'm trying
to I'm trying to CCH it so he knows what
we're thinking
yeah speak are you going to Prejudice
anything in the future I can't read his
mind whe you it quiet just ask you yeah
yeah wait until we close session I mean
um
he is your
judgment do you
want is to stay within the don't send me
a note like
that if it goes into the public domain
close
session well we haven't advertised a
close session session so we can't read
down we shouldn't do that it's not a
good practice to suddenly you know
decide just the me in the wrong
place on that basis
you if if we come back we can come back
and talk about it again yeah there's no
reason why yeah we close the meeting if
there's no if there's something that
comes up we can put it on our work list
and we will bring it back again in the
New
Year okay good thank you very much
indeed for attending thank you very much
visitors I
your explanations and uh comments have
been very very open very honest and and
very well received thank you very much
indeed as
well